hasta ahora el ceo de tiktok insiste en
que son una empresa privada y niega
vínculos con el gobierno de shijing
Sí pero las preocupaciones de los
oficiales acá en Washington y también de
los congresistas en el Capitolio Es que
la información los datos de cerca de 150
millones de usuarios de tiktok acá en
Estados Unidos terminen en manos de las
autoridades chinas de las autoridades en
Beijing que podrían dicen varios
congresistas usar esta información para
hacer campañas de desinformación como en
el 2016 lo hizo Rusia para favorecer sus
intereses políticos en Estados Unidos al
respecto sin embargo el ceo de tiktok en
está en esta en esta clasificación que
está haciendo en el congreso dice que no
hay evidencia de que información y datos
de tiktok de estadounidenses terminen en
manos de las autoridades chinas sin
embargo congresistas en esta audiencia
que se llevó a cabo en el congreso están
diciendo que es contradictorio el hecho
de que un Memo interno se haya filtrado
en medios locales donde decía que
de trataba de decir a los empleados de
tiktok que minimizaran las declaraciones
y las afirmaciones de que tiktok tenía
vínculos con China y estaba pasando
información al gobierno de Pekín
entonces pues transcurre esta audiencia
en medio de muchos cuestionamientos para
el lesión de tiktok que responde
diciendo que no hay evidencia
precisamente de que esta información
termine en manos de autoridades chinas
efectivamente el panorama de tiktok en
el país no es positivo el propio
Gobierno Federal ya prohíbe sus
empleados usar tiktok pero también ha
amenazado incluso con sacarla por
completo del país
sí amenazado Y esta amenaza además viene
de gobiernos anteriores el expresidente
Donald Trump también intentó sacar a
tiktok de el país y recientemente yo
vayan le dijo a tiktok que si no vendía
su operación y si no vendía la
plataforma que tiene acá en Estados
Unidos a una empresa estadounidense
entonces iba a prohibir la plataforma la
red social en este país la venta Sería
para la empresa Oracle que se quedaría
no solamente con la plataforma sino
también con los datos con toda la
información de los 150 millones de
usuarios que tiene tiktok en Estados
Unidos sin embargo pues no pudo Donald
Trump vender y forzar la venta de esta
aplicación de red social y muchos dicen
que va a ser muy complicado para Joe
biden forzar esta venta y si eso no se
logra la Casa Blanca tendría dos
opciones por un lado no permitir que
esta aplicación siga siendo difundida o
el día descargada
en las aplicaciones y en las plataformas
como Apple el apóstol la tienda de Apple
o la tienda de Google y la otra opción
sería simplemente forzar a que los datos
de texto queden en Estados Unidos
también en bases de datos controladas
por empresas estadounidenses